each year on december 10th thousands of
worshipers convene
in scandinavia to commemorate the death
of a man once known as the merchant of
death
this catacological ritual features all
the rights and incantations
befitting a pharaoh's funeral haunting
durge's play
as the worshipers be decked in mandatory
regalia
mourn the merchant he is eerily present
his visage
looms large over the congregants as they
feast
an exotic game surrounded by fresh cut
flowers
imported from the deceased merchant of
death's
mausoleum the event culminates with the
presentation
of gilded graven images bearing his
likeness
this ritual is of course the annual
nobel prize award ceremonies
held every year not on the date of
alfred nobel's birth
but on december 10th the day he left
this mortal coil
and today you're in for a treat a
conversation
with a very alive ray weiss
who those of us who know him know him to
be nothing if not
incredibly incredibly interesting
provocative
mercurial mischievous and an all-around
delight
i talked to him about so many things in
this wide-ranging interview it's really
one of the highlights
of my career and it's fitting we did so
on december 10th which is today
uh the anniversary of the great alfred
nobel's dis
uh last breath on this planet
i heard some never before discussed
stories about some of the personalities
behind the pursuit of gravitational
waves
ranging back even to einstein's day but
even
closer to in time to people who sadly as
well have passed away
including joe weber and ron drever who
are characters in my book
as well and losing the nobel prize as
well as in other accounts of the famous
story
of detection of gravitational waves from
black holes in 2015 and 2016
in the announcement that reverberated
around the planet
resulting in nobel prizes for three
gentlemen
two of whom i have now uh had on the
show and the third one kept thorn i'm
hoping to have on
in the near future you're gonna hear
rey's advice for life
and he's a real live wire he talks uh
incessantly and and persuasively about
why it's important to do something
you're curious about
even if it means that you change
directions in your career
every five years reevaluating these
fundamental
questions that rey will always ask
himself even now
at age 88 he is still going strong he is
still sharp as attack
what are those questions tune in and
you'll find out and you'll also find out
about
lessons that you can apply even if
you're not a physicist looking for wispy
imprints
of the big bang in my case or in ray's
case of of collisions of massive stars
billions of light years away from earth
you'll learn about how to form a team of
rivals
how to persist when those rivals
seemingly
turn their backs on you and maybe even
in the whole project
you agreed to go ahead with you'll also
learn about his upbringing
and how different it was and how you can
get a little taste of
the kind of curiosity that he had and
instill that
in either in yourself or also in your
children or people that you
uh are close to young people that you're
close to to keep
your projects your science your research
whatever you're doing to keep
it interesting and fun and these are the
key
traits and takeaways you're going to
learn on this episode i had just such a
spectacular time ray is a hero of mine
and i can't wait you're gonna hear about
his new book that's coming out
uh written with barry barrish past guest
on the into the impossible
podcast as well as uh kip thorne who i
do hope
to get on the podcast you'll hear some
other nobel list name dropped but not
for merely the sake of name dropping
but to really investigate what's wrong
with the nobel prize and how is ray
personally going about trying to rectify
the various ills that he perceives is
existing within the current nobel prize
structure
nevertheless he still believes it's
crucially important and it's hard to
argue with him
i tried my best i didn't succeed but i
hope you'll enjoy going into the
impossible
with none other than the legendary
professor
ray weiss enjoy
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
but i do want to start so i'll start now
by welcoming
everybody to this episode of the into
the impossible podcast
i am your fearful host brian keating
during these pandemic podcasts
today it's quite a treat to talk to a
hero of mine
although he doesn't remember it we've
met a few times at mit when i've had the
honor of visiting there and speaking
there
but i left my normal insignificant
impression upon him as i do on many
people but
it's quite a thrill to have none other
than ray weiss a legend
uh in his own time ray welcome where are
you joining us from today
well i'm at home in newton but let me
correct something that you said
i didn't remember but now you tell me
yes of course i remember
okay but when we never work together
that's what i
and that to me is the thing that makes
me really memorable have memorable
things okay
yeah i know you gave a colloquium but
you know okay
right yeah you you fell asleep after
alan guth fell asleep no i didn't know
alan always falls asleep i never fall
asleep
i did not listen that's something
exactly well right you have been a
mentor and in many ways i wish that i
had worked with you or had the chance to
work with you
and you know who knows maybe i'll i'll
help proofread your upcoming
book yeah but i want to introduce you so
ray weiss born in september 1932 is an
american physicist
known for his contributions to
gravitational physics and astrophysics
he's a professor emeritus at mit
and so he's one of the leaders of the
ligo experiment for which he received a
share of the 2017 nobel prize in physics
so ray as you know today is december
10th do you recall where you were
two years ago on this date three the
only way the only reason why i think
you're i might remember is because you
asked i
i think it has to do with nobel prize
because a lot of what you're thinking
about
but i wouldn't have known that unless
you would ask that and it's it's
actually not
it is the typical day is the day that
you received the nobel prize of course
in stockholm in uh in uh in 2017
uh but it's also the anniversary of the
death of alfred nobel i always find it
interesting i did not know that
okay yeah they give away the nobel
prizes not on his birthday
as a sane society might do but on the
day of his death it's kind of a
scatological as they say
well i mean what do you want to know i
mean what did he start he started
dynamite right
so you've got to be careful with a guy
like that exactly and
actually he started the prize it's
rumored i talk about this in my book
that he started the prize out of some
sense of guilt that he had
for both the destructive power of
dynamite but also because
his brother died his older brother
ludwig died in 1888
and the parisian newspaper that in the
city that he was living in paris
printed a headline that said alfred
nobel the merchant of death is dead and
they were kind of gleefully celebrating
alfred nobel's death and so this is like
you know ebenezer scrooge or you know
somebody george george bailey
finding out and it's a wonderful life
how people are going to react and so
death plays a big role in the nobel
prize in fact i do want to talk to you
about the death of your colleague ron
drever um
you know who who even barry you know i
had a conversation with barry barrish
your colleague and and friend
uh and i want to talk to you uh first
and foremost uh what is the best
aspect of winning a nobel prize and
what's the worst i've heard you describe
it in german as you know it's an
additional thing in
in german which i can't pronounce but
there's some word in german like
cranker i mean but in addition
but no look it's a complicated story and
uh
i'll let me be dead honest with you when
i was younger and
and i have and i had never had much
interest in the nobel prize
it was not something on my mind uh and
uh
and i even when it happened i was
i had double feelings about it okay and
i'll tell you what it is and that's
something that
you may because you are close to it too
it have
worried about is that how do you now
and i'm not saying anything profound
that others haven't said but it's got to
be said
and that is in our day and age when
you're talking about people
you're a member of i don't know how many
people in your group several hundred in
the
okay i'm in a thing which which has
certainly from caltech and mit alone
50 or so people and then a collaboration
which consists of another thousand or so
uh that these are the people who
actually
i didn't not that i didn't do something
too but this was a
great big group of people and it's sort
of
awkward for to be pulled out of that
group and given something which is
actually a group effort and
i know that that that's part of the
mystique of this thing united it's part
of the thing is the hardest
to to to really come to grips with
um i mean the the thing is
how when you now have a large scientific
effort going on and that's true whether
you're doing cosmic background work or
the b
modes or the cosmic you know any almost
all almost any large project nowadays
it's it's it was not thought about by
the people by
if nobel if that's the person we have to
blame or give the credit to
it's not the way we do science anymore
that is an individual who
is the person who is responsible
you they in fact i think that they must
have a terrible time
especially the committees that look at
this to decide who and they must do the
terrible investigations
to find out well you know this guy did
it and this guy did it but he did a
little more than
i mean i can imagine the arguments that
go on in in the nobel prize committee
meetings i've been on others so i know
the gruber prize for example i know
exactly what goes on
and so it's very awkward then to be in a
pulled out
and the only way i came to terms with it
is to say i am
i can't change the way the world goes
but i can
try to make myself into something which
is halfway believable
namely i can be a symbol for the others
yes
and that's the only way i can i can take
that thing okay in all your talks in all
your talks including your ted talk
you first and foremost always give
credit to the team and say basically
you're a stand and cut out for
the rest of nothing but it's true it's
true it's not just the crazy modesty
it's it's
it's true and and i understand why they
can't do it
now i know the the people who are trying
to get around that
and i i wish them luck is the the
breakthrough people yeah
they're they're trying to do it with the
whole team and i'm very pleased that
that you can do that
uh it but it does and i had discussions
with the people in the nobel committee
when i was there about this
not that look i'm sure everybody who
parts a part of a team has that
kind of feeling yeah and actually the
peace prize is owned by team
it was won by a team this year the world
food program
yeah so the thing is that that that what
so that's a complicated thing it's a
complexity that comes with it for an
experimenter
the good parts of it is uh and i think
the world needs
certain symbols and the symbols in this
case are symbols that
here is something that the society
thinks is
something that they really they relish
they they think it's good
and they have given it as a thing as a
symbol to
that science is something which the
society badly wants
and loves okay and that piece of it
is the part that we all share so you
don't want to screw it up
by dumping on it okay and that's one of
the things that is very tricky about
this
and the thing is that part of it being
able to
talk to people especially high school
kids grade school kids
they're all over you because i've got
nobel prize a big deal you know but on
top of that i've done this for years but
even way before the nobel prize i've
been talking to
kids in high schools and grade schools
because i love to do it but
now it has a significance that they take
a little more let's say they're a little
more
they're a little more serious about it
and i did that
and i hope i convinced some people that
they ought to go into science
you know i mean that's worth something
[Music]
yeah absolutely and i think i think you
know what's so striking to me i asked
two of your colleagues
and friends uh one your colleague at mit
frank wilczyk
uh winner of the 2004 nobel prize and i
asked your friend barry barish
co-winner with you i asked them do you
ever suffer from the imposter syndrome
of course and only one of the two of
them said yes and i want to ask you
which one do you think said yes and then
do you suffer from the impostor syndrome
i
suffered for it right away i can tell
you where i cannot guess between frank
and
and barry i won't i don't want to
challenge that one you tell me
okay uh i because i i know them a little
i know barry well and i don't know we'll
check so well
okay and i um i mean i will check's a
very bright man and i love to listen to
him talk
he's just full of ideas and barry is a
superb physicist
and uh and an organizer a par excellence
but uh so i don't you tell me but what
what what what the imposter thing was
i'll tell you
what i think we all share that but most
of us do is that
you go to this thing and i always
remember looking at the
the king see i'll tell you a little bit
maybe you know
all the mores of this the old there were
three of us that's in our case okay
standing there looking like he badly
needed a smoke
you know i mean that uh you know he was
he wasn't old and tottering but he
looked to me very uncomfortable
i said and here is this heavy thing that
is holding
and how we can make sure that neither of
us drop the goddamn thing okay
and uh so my worry was let's make sure
we don't screw up
either of us and that was my biggest
thinking as i was walking toward the guy
and then walking away from him i said
this is ridiculous
i mean look where where where does i how
do i fit in the same group
as as heisenberg or you know or or fermi
or
you name it i mean this is a completely
nonsense
and so that's where the impostor thing
comes in okay
that's what barry said too barry said he
he looked and he saw this little guy
uh he saw the signature of this guy in
the book i guess you have to sign this
book
take delivery of your law and and barry
said um
no i didn't i i couldn't take it i got
and i got goosebumps
thinking about you know barry we all
have tremendous respect for for barry
and if this guy has imposter syndrome
what help is there for me
and then i talked to frank a day or two
later and i said frank you discovered
the
phenomenon that would eventually lead to
your nobel prize when you were 21 or 22
you didn't receive that nobel prize
until
you were 50 something years old 30
31 years later in 2004. um
was that excruciating for you and how
did you deal with it and he had already
said that he never felt the imposter
syndrome
he kind of felt the anti-imposter
syndrome like he he knew enough that he
should know even more
effectively as frank's taken and all
those of us who know him
know that that's that's he's sort of
this wonderkind and and uh
just just an amazing scientist um in the
grand tradition
but uh he said that it was excruciating
to wait
you know for 30 years plus to receive
this you know this
i call it the golden engraven image i
have a piece of hanukkah guilt here
today is also hanukkah
yeah yeah so uh you know this one's
about 10 years old from when i went to
the gift shop there in stockholm but um
what were you there for well you were
waiting you were there for john mather
or what
no no i i didn't go to i went to um
there was a conference at the um
at nordita in the um in stockholm and i
couldn't resist stopping by this is
about ten years ago and kind of you know
dreaming about it but
uh but it was it's just so interesting
to think you know
everything that you've done it seemed
like yeah you're it's sort of this
additional thing that is nice you're not
gonna turn it down it's interesting no
people have turned down the nobel peace
prize the nobel prize in literature
but no one's ever turned down a physics
prize and i i wonder why
why that is um i also wonder why you
know with people like einstein you know
who was denied it for many years as you
probably know because of
him being jewish and practicing what was
considered non-aryan science
well that that was part of it no
einstein got the award for
one of his interesting stuff but not the
most important thing he'd done yeah
as you know they couldn't settle on
special relativity they couldn't settle
on general rule to be i mean that was
completely
off the rock i mean you know and nobody
had really proved that that
oh my god yes that was just too modern
no that was the problem
the jewish stuff came later i think
that's at least look i look i
i know a little because i i've had well
i mean the people who really went after
einstein were
were stark and abraham now that's
abraham but mostly stark
and leonard leonardo and lenard yeah
lenard
and uh they went and stark in particular
was particularly unattractive about this
yes and i hate to think of it my my
thesis as a scene
as a phd thesis was measuring the stark
effect i could never get over it
well i think you know einstein you know
basically provided the theoretical
underpinning for the lennard effect you
know which is kind of ironic yeah
yeah and that's why he won the nobel
prize or at least that was the citation
the photo electric effect and brownie in
motion and contributions you know kind
of a grab bag but
i want to ask you i've been doing a lot
of interviews i've interviewed people
like uh carl
um weeman wyman rather and uh
and then barry uh but most of i've had
the chance to interview people like adam
reese
who's an observer and uh and other
people that are more on the theoretical
side like frank and shelley glashow
crosstown
rival of yours and in the boston area uh
and
and i noted that you know when you hear
about black holes and you hear about
you know einstein and wormholes and and
roger penrose
was on the show a couple of weeks ago
too and of course he just won the half
share of the nobel prize in 2020.
and i wonder why do you uh what do you
think is the reason that i missed it
you went uh we went dead for a second oh
sorry i wanna i wanna know why do you
think that the nobel
prize has recognized experimentalists
and
and observers much more than theorists
and yet in the popular imagination
the theorists get a lot more attention i
mean kip thorne you know is known
for many things but especially you know
his work on interstellar
and you look at and roger penrose and
and even people like stephen hawking
making these contributions as theorists
for things that were never observed like
a singularity has never been observed
directly
um we've never you know observed a
wormhole and and people will talk about
it as if they're as real as the actual
detections that you make so i guess
what is your take on the difference in
prestige of a theoretical
scientist versus an experimental
scientist like like you or me
well that's a complicated question i
mean uh
the uh
i don't know enough of the history of
the early nobel prizes but
most of the people who won nobel prizes
in the early days
what i mean by that is before the
revolution of quantum mechanics and so
forth
were well they were you know pretty
pedestrian i mean some of those things
you know the guy who invented a
particular way of making a loud
lighthouse go around yes the land gustav
yeah i don't know them all but
that that you know eventually they they
got
around to understanding what were the
things that might be considered
important by others
but the thing is that i think the there
isn't
in in the physics of your europe during
the epic of
this i do know from people like vicky
weiskopf
who had lived through this and others
who i know
in the early days of physics in europe
and i mean by that
let's say the time when the photo to
photo effect was discovered
and it was the experimenters that were
considered
the people who did everything in other
words and
theorists were considered something
which was more mathematical
they were not really the scientists they
were it was and you'll you look ahead
and you'll see
you look back it took a while for this
that group of people in sweden to
recognize
theoretical theoretical work in the
united states it was the other way
around
i think the theorists were more at least
you probably know better than i because
you've been
studying this but i think there was a
higher acceptance of theorists much
more quickly and i have a funny feeling
about
why that might be the case and just this
is a surmise on my part
and that is that uh the
i'm not sure this is right but and i
think it has to do with our in our case
with people who made opinions
for example uh aye aye robbie do you
i think you it certainly was a forget
about the nobel prize for a minute was a
central figure in american physics
yeah uh and when he was at columbia he's
colombia was the center of physics in
the country i mean let's face it
in the 30s and mid-30s and so forth and
he had a i mean i met i know him i mean
i worked on stuff that he
that he had worked on too my my the guy
who was my thesis advisor was one of his
postdocs
and also later on very close friend of i
robbie so
i got to meet robbie in both as in his
manic ways and he was wild by the way
and on top of
because he was extremely aggressive
about certain things and that's not
going to all of that but he was a very
interesting person
and he began to realize that the
work in this country was well
divided between theory and experiment
see a lot of stuff he was doing in the
atomic beam business
couldn't been i could not have been done
without people like schwinger who helped
them out
people you know other people who had
been around understanding the quantum
mechanics
at a level which was complicated let's
face it where
you had to deal with and this wasn't
just matrix mechanics it was quite
complicated and comp
to think it through and then all these
clips gordon coefficients and all this
mathematics oh my god
they needed theorists okay and so
instead of being the handmaiden
of the of the experimenters they became
individuals on their own
i think that happened faster in the
united states than in europe
that's just my guess i mean they that
does comport with the history at least
as far as i
referenced it they actually would look
down upon
you know people that did theoretical
science in europe uh
you know because real men did did
experimental science according to
and i of course i've been i've been uh
on on the on the on
i mean later when i got into my age of
being in physics
i resented the theorists because they
they represented
what was important to do in other words
i always said screw it i have
ideas about this too right and uh you
know my
idea is even though i can't formulate
them as beautifully as you can they're
just as good yeah and i i want to work
on things that i'm interested in the
hell with what you telling me that's
more important than
something else and i had the opposite
thing i didn't like the theorists
getting in the way of everything okay
that's a that's my own hang up okay
that's a different problem
right i want to talk about that in terms
of pedagogy and how
um how things have gotten i've really
changed even since i was a kid you know
30 40 years ago
between then and now i used to be able
to buy a chemistry set
and it had you know ferric acid and it
had hydrochloric you know it had all
this stuff
nowadays i've got a bunch of kids and
and they're into chemistry i buy them a
set
and it's like you know this warning do
not ingest the contents of this thing
and it's and what is that what are the
contents is it you know
hydrofluoric acid no it's vinegar and
baking soda
and some chalk and that's it and and i
wonder you go back to what your story i
wonder if we
if you wouldn't mind recounting it how
you got you know basically
battled of raging inferno to get
equipment to build
phonographic record players to build
stereo high five
what have we lost with the with the art
of tinkering i mean nowadays
my kids can't even work on a car i mean
not that they're old enough to work oh
neither can you i mean
i know that that's what i'm saying right
it's a goddamn computer that's killed
that but
so talk about you know that pedagogy at
the early age your auto didact that
learned about uh
experimental radar from surplus kits and
things that would kill you nowadays so
well now be careful with that i look i
think my my own instinct is i know
exactly what you're saying
yeah uh i mean you used to be able to go
to a drug store and buy mercury i don't
know if you know that yeah that's true
and many of us had pockets full of
mercury i mean
you know because it was fun to look at
and it it quick silver
yeah yeah quicksilver of course so
anyway no it was a complete change i
think it has to do with
with lawyers it has to do with the
litigation
aspect of our country so i don't know if
it's the same in europe
i don't know i don't know if it's the
same in china or or india that's worth
finding out
but most of the people that i know of
who
had experiments and this is where it's
different
your kids you buy a kit that's because
that's one way to do it but many of the
people who
have gone into experimental physics
let's say a while ago
got most of their experience by being
the fixer in the house doing things you
know
like i'm not i'm not denigrating your
children because they want to work on
chemistry sets but
you know it's always very good to have
for example a kid
who works with her in a garage again
works with people in a garage
or works with a plumber as an apprentice
or works with an electrician as
apprentice
hey i think and i recommend that over
and over again when our people high
school kids say
to me what should i do to be able to do
physics i said go
rent yourself off to a guy and learn
something yeah yeah you developed a
trade you had to trade at a 14 year old
yeah
exactly and that then teaches you a
couple of things
the most important thing is it teaches
you to how to problem-solve
in other words you watch the others
here's something that's screwed up you
try this you try that and you begin to
make a you know a venn diagram you don't
say it that way
but you say yep it's not it's none of
these things so you said
there's two about it and so eventually
you get it so
i don't know i mean for example most of
the people that were in my generation
that went into physics did that kind of
thing they
it isn't they i didn't i didn't remember
having chemistry sets that's
that's the thing you know i'm not saying
you shouldn't have chemistry no yeah i
mean i also had i worked on a car as a
16 year old because i couldn't afford to
get it repaired you know and that was
like a
1979 car yeah yeah that was good for you
you learned more from that than you
could imagine that's right yeah
i always ask my students you know they
sent me oh i've gotten you know all this
java coding and i've gotten this
differential geometry i'm like do you
know how to weld
like tell me something cool something
something interesting that you can do
with your hands and um and uniformly i
think they've gotten a distance from it
but i i would be remiss if i didn't ask
you to talk about those useful skills
that you
what drove you to do that right because
it's not normal even for kids back then
i mean they said feynman
used to fix radios and queens by
thinking about it so he would hire
himself
out and he was a theorist or uh and you
were doing the same kind of thing but
with record players what we used to call
record players or phonographs
uh talk about that and and this neat
kind of
relationship between the microscopic
vibrations of a tiny needle
uh and then the reverberations of
space-time i mean do you feel like
there's any connection there it seems
too good to be you're trying to you're
making it too dramatic okay yeah yeah
okay
that's right there is a connection and
people have noticed this which i didn't
realize but
it's the noise but that noise is the
thing that kills you in one
and kills you in the other two i mean if
you're interested in music you don't
want noise i mean have you ever listened
to a ford a 78 record
of course yeah yeah well
45 also 40 well 45s and 33s have vinyl
that's they're different no i know i
know the old ones had about sherlock or
something
well that's right exactly and the
shellac records were terrible and you
noticed it especially if you were
interested in listening
to slow quiet music like the second
movement of a beethoven sonata
it gets destroyed by that goddamn hiss
okay
and uh so you know that was that was my
big problem when i had
to do things no look i don't i cannot
tell you a good i don't have
a nice story to say of an uncle or of my
father or anybody like that
why i got interested in electronics i
think it had to do with availability
it's a puzzle yeah it seems like it was
a puzzle you love to solve these puzzles
no
it had to do with the end of the second
world war all things
have to do with certain events that
happen and i remember i used to be a guy
who would
love to go to cortland street in new
york i don't know you're not from new
york
i am from new york yeah oh good yeah
cortland street
is down where the world straight well no
no it's it's
north north of the battery but it's it's
pretty much near where the world trade
center was
and uh you could go down to fort
cortlandt street this is
during during the war you couldn't find
much but by by 1944 1945
when i was saying i was 13 12 something
like that
uh and i read popular mechanics and
popular science a lot
and uh that kind of those those
magazines
and they still exist i think but popular
mechanics may not but
and you know in there you could make a
relay that would keep a
make a rat trap that would close the
door when you cut the rat i mean
we had rat problems so we had to build
things like that okay so
the anyway the the problem the thing was
that
in my case it was simply that there was
so much stuff coming back
as salvage from the second world war
that it was
i just saw it on the sidewalk and i said
what's this what's that
and i know you know and i had friends
who in those
some of the people ran those stores yeah
they told me hey we got a nice thing
just came back from
you know south pacific you'll have to
get the varnish off it if you want to do
it
but we got a whole radar set there and
you want you want the oscilloscope
then sure i want the oscilloscope how
much is it worth oh i don't know a
couple of bucks something like that i
mean that was a big deal a couple of
books so
yeah okay anyway so that's it it was i
don't know was the availability i'm
telling you i don't i cannot give you
a you know a a specific purpose a
pacifistic
source the thing is that in my life the
thing that was important was music
and there was at that time in new york
and i won't go into this much more but
what was the fact that all of a sudden i
didn't have the discipline to learn how
to play an instrument
that takes discipline later on in my
life i tried to do it i'm still doing it
but i never got any good i'm not really
good at it but
uh but so i would i was interested in
what you could pick up on
you know making electronics because that
was a lot easier than learning an
instrument
and uh it was very we were that was a
lucky coincidence of three things that
happened
and that's what started the whole thing
one was the junk on cortland street
okay the other one was that there was a
movie theater in brooklyn that had a
fire behind the screen
and i was able to pick up these altec
lansing loudspeakers
by unscrewing them from the back of the
screen
and the third thing was that fm radio
was coming in
and fm radio already existed but it had
become commercial
and you could now pick up on fm radio
which is full dynamic range
and 20 hertz to 20 kilohertz kind of
sound uh and you could listen to you
know the new york philharmonic
on the radio and it sounded like you
were right in the hall and that i built
several of those things with those
speakers and all that stuff and that
started a business
which is uh it was never intended i mean
i would invite
other immigrant kid parents you know
europeans love music too i mean many of
the jewish families that came were
interested in classical music and stuff
like that i had friends whose parents
were
and they and they would come over and
listen to this setup and they would say
god this is fantastic can you build us
one
you know and i yeah i'll do it for parts
but eventually i didn't realize how many
people wanted that
and i got into real trouble and then the
phonograph record was the last piece of
it and that was an unsolved problem
insoluble problem because i tried i see
that's where
the difference which one i call street
electronics which is what i knew
which you know street electronic all
this sort of half-assed experience that
some of it's right some of it's wrong
you know but you have enough so you can
get things done
but then with real certain mathematics
applied to it that's a different story
that's real engineering
and i didn't have that so the challenge
was how do you get rid of that goddamn
record hiss
and there were certain properties of it
that you knew it all it had high
frequencies in it mostly
and it also it always was there when the
music was quiet so
could you make a thing that changed the
bandwidth of the system as the music was
loud and soft
that was an idea which sort of was quite
obvious later on the people
who really knew how to do that did it
right but but i didn't know enough and
so what
all the cures that i could come up with
were worse than the disease the disease
okay but it got you acquainted with uh
solving oh yeah i got you doing that
yeah yeah i went to college for that
reason
i'd try to solve that problem you
actually as i recall you dropped out of
uh well you dropped out of uh it was a
college or graduate school i forgot
i dropped out if i dropped that was a
different story that's
that has to do with being sort of a kid
and being adolescent
no i ran into a wonderful girl who was a
spectacular pianist
and uh i just couldn't live without her
and uh but she could live without me and
that was the problem
and that eventually brought you to uh to
princeton right no no
no that took me to chicago where she was
a student and then i flunked out
and then the transformation and this if
you're interested in the transformation
that transformation took place after i
flunked out this was in the
middle of the junior year at mit and uh
i i walked all around an old building at
mit called building 20
which is where the radar was developed
and i found a lab which
looked to me like they could use an
electronics technician and it turned out
they could
and i became a union member i dropped
out of school completely and became a
card carrying a union member and became
electronics technician for a couple of
years
in a nab of gerald zacharias's and he is
the guy who saved me
in every way possible and the thing he
was working on
in the end was atomic clocks and
he wanted to do he put me into the bug
of einstein he
but he the experiment he proposed to me
was after we got to know each other well
and uh
and i have since i was expendable i
wasn't taking i was not a student
you know i didn't there was no
responsibility there was no phd to give
you know nothing like that
so he said i want to do an experiment he
said to me where you and i
and maybe somebody else we build some
new clocks which are better than the
ones we have
and we'll do this experiment in in
switzerland you with your new clock will
be on top of the jungfrau
and i will he will be down in the in the
valley
and in the jungfrau valley and we will
send signals to each other from
these atomic clocks and measure the
einstein redshift
that was that was the big experiment we
were going to do
and they and what happened was is that
this fancy clock that he had
invented to do this didn't work and
that's a long story i don't think i want
to go into it but i do want to
i have heard you describe that the the
cesium fountain or the beams and so
forth
i i don't want to talk about that
specifically but i want to talk about a
general question
in the philosophy which i don't think
gets talked about as much i know you're
not like huge into philosophy but the
philosophy of experimental science
and this question is as follows how do
you know when to shut off an experiment
we can always turn on an experiment keep
it going if you keep shoveling in more
money in the nsf which we'll get into
keeps approving your funds and you have
graduate students and they don't abandon
you
but um but when do you shut it off when
how do you acquire that wisdom or
judgment because i think that applies to
things outside of science as well
well i mean i have only i have several
example of that because i failed in a
few
places my first failure was making a
better clock okay that was not i was a
technician at the time but still and uh
what happened is gerald is the one who
gave up gerald he had
very big fish to fry for example and
this was all in 1956 i mean before
most people that i know were born okay
and
the uh and uh
what what happened he got the idea that
american
secondary and primary education in
science and mathematics
was really screwed up and he was right
so in 1956 he got an
idea of how to fix that and you're
probably uh
a beneficiary of that i don't know it
was called the
physical sciences study committee really
right and they did a beautiful job write
a really
modern textbook and so forth among other
things they also then
so he decided that he was going to quit
that experiment it was for him was he
had more important things to do
right well what did i have to do i want
to find out why the goddamn thing didn't
work
right and so i didn't cost anything the
thing was there
and so we found out what was wrong i
mean it took it took a couple of months
to do that
uh and it and and in fact there's a flaw
in
the way we teach statistical mechanics
uh i don't know
i mean i might as well tell you right
off yeah it's uh but the idea of this
clock was that
the big idea of getting a better clock
was always to get more observation
time for the looking at the atomic
system the longer you could do that
the smaller the uncertainty and the
frequency okay that i mean that was the
basic idea
and so what you do or you use higher
frequencies that was the other way of
doing it
but you were stuck here with cesium 10
killer 10 gigahertz okay
so the idea was to how do you get in an
ordinary apparatus a small atomic clock
that takes a
millisecond you have about a millisecond
to watch the atom
and he said well let's can't we get up
to about a second to do this
okay that would give you a factor of a
thousand and he
his idea was to throw them up like
baseballs
like a fountain yeah make a fountain
well sounds i mean what did i know it's
just used today yeah of course it works
beautifully
it's called the zechariah's fountain
yeah and uh
but it didn't work in those days for for
a very simple reason you're dealing with
a
tiny part of the fraction of the of the
boltzmann distribution in the beam
you know one twentieth maybe one
thirtieth and the fast guys are coming
back and they're hitting you in the
tuckers
okay so here here's this beam going up
and trying to come down again
and the fast atoms are many many of them
and what they eventually do is throw all
the
slow ones out of the beam interesting
that was the problem
ah and as if you start and i i was able
to prove that
by putting uh measuring the time of
flight at different heights in this
apparatus
but the apparatus grew to be 30 three
floors high
because we never did didn't want to give
up looking for faster atoms faster
no no none of them worked and so
consequently what happened is that uh
nowadays as you as you point out you can
take and make a that's how these some of
these clocks work
you can take a ordinary you know a
standard clock now let's say
on the sodium over so any of the optical
clocks and lift it up by a centimeter
slit it up by a centimeter and you can
measure the redshift yeah it's
pretty amazing but in 1957 you couldn't
right one horsepower
that's how pound eventually did it yeah
and uh
and that became the whole thing became
less interesting but
it was that business of learning what
einstein and learning about einstein
and how he was how he thought i fell in
love with the guy i mean that was the
that was fundamentally the end of it
he's had a you know he had a reputation
for some blunders you know
of course i know them all and that's not
the point do you know what his most
do you notice most cited paper is ray
i i don't know which is this it's the uh
epr paradox paper oh that's a shitty
i'm sorry i know that no i know that
it's i know it shouldn't be
it's a crappy paper it's a bad idea and
i hate that paper
and it's i think it's podolski's uh
podolski's way of staying a citizen
staying in the united states it was all
that very complicated thing where he was
trying to help all these immigrants who
he had assembled around him
and he's any you know and he if he
hadn't been the first author of that
paper
nobody would have read it i think that's
a joke yeah and and it really
was uh i think they had animus towards
each or
he had resentment at least towards
podolski
ever uh ever after but getting back to
the experimental you know kind of
shutting down so as you know from being
one of the pioneers
in the field of cosmic microwave
background radiation research
uh you know i always point out you know
kobe could have detected
you know the polarization of the
microwave background if you kept it
running for
like 100 years or something like that
just to make an extreme case
uh in other words we win but we win very
slowly with time we only win as the
square root of time so to get twice as
good you need four times as much time
so i want to ask you when you make a
decision to end
a lot is it like you know like killing
your pet worm
or or is it like you know unplugging a
computer what does it feel like
to end an experiment that's successful
yeah but
let me let me say it's always something
a little different than what you think
maybe take that's a good example um
you could have run kobe for a long time
except you wouldn't have been able to
liquid helium wouldn't last that's a
real problem okay
and on top of that where they were
detectors you would not wouldn't even
think of using anymore
i mean as they were so crude you know
kilometers with to the minus 15 nep
or something like that yeah you you
wouldn't even touch them anymore that's
ridiculous
so it turns out generally you give up on
i mean generally when i gave up on
experiments
it's either one of where you want to
know what went wrong because there was
something wrong and i learned something
out of that
okay i learned that the maxwell
distribution doesn't work okay
in a beam that's a piece of knowledge
that you ought to tell people about
okay that's that's that's a result okay
on the other hand most of the time it is
that you've worked on it it hasn't
worked
you do the noise analysis and you've
convinced yourself that you need another
two orders of magnitude or something
like that when you finally understand
the experiment now
and then you say i can't do that that's
just too big a jump
and then you find that then somewhere
later in your life you suddenly find out
oh my god
here's this piece of technology that
solves that problem that i worked on
that didn't work before and sometimes
that
was very useful and by the way that's
remarkably what happened in the
ligo a lot and ligo for example
the fact that nova none of us gave much
attention to squeezed light for example
yeah okay and then all of a sudden it
turns out that yeah oh my god we can use
this
you know and uh that was right baginski
was
that was his calling card for many years
now his be careful with that one
you're right but not quite right okay uh
what it was is that
breginsky saw right away that a
mechanical bar would be troubled by the
quantum limit in other words
that the thing that senses the bar is
going to put enough noise into it
the quantum noise into it so that it'll
mask the signal
and then he tried and he didn't come up
with a very good way of doing that first
he kept thinking about something he
called non-quantum non-demolition
detector systems and these are all
second order things
these are still i don't think they've
paid off yet but they will
they will it's ideal that you it's i
don't know the closest thing to it is
which i it's funny that people now talk
about measuring weak
weak measurements do you know what i'm
talking about where you don't actually
force the system
into an eigen state right yeah it's a
second order kind of
perturbation theory right yeah exactly
and uh and that
is what he was actually i think pushing
and the guy who actually is responsible
for
the squeezing and his application is
carlton caves i don't know if you know
of him
he was a he was probably at caltech when
you were celtic
he was a student of chip thorns and kip
by the way this is something you don't
probably don't know about kim
kip has a very uh
uh what i will call tactile sense about
physics
it's it's not he's a theorist yes and
he's a he
he doesn't make mistakes when he makes
equations like i do
but uh you know he thinks he does right
but he also has a wonderful
feeling in his gut about the physics and
let me say what he did
uh kip did two things he convinced
carlton that there was something wrong
with the way we thought about
where the noise comes in into the
interferometer i don't know
it comes it's a long story i don't think
i want to tell it unless you want it
but the important thing is that the
cartilage discovery was that the noise
which we had always thought
was shot noise and momentum noise which
is the other two noises that come in a
photon system that those were
independent
in a way of each other and they're not
and it turns out they come in not where
you think it is they come in where the
detector is
there they are fluctuations in the in
the vacuum field
and that vacuum fluctuation distributes
itself in the interferometer in such a
way
that it you if you could somehow reduce
the vacuum fluctuations coming in the
dark part of the interferometer
you could win and that is squeezing
ah okay oh so it wasn't the uh kind of
complementarity that breginsky brokens
yeah it was very different very
different yeah actually i didn't
appreciate that until just now
and what it is is and then just one step
further so you'll have a little bit it's
very easy to see it what what you
require is paired photons
which one you would do is repair photons
at the dark port
so that they either have as a pair they
have amplitude sidebands or
phase modulation sidebands and those are
the two
variables that are the quantum uh
canonical
yeah the conjugates okay and so
consequently you can adjust that
whether you make the two a pair of
photons you see what the way it does you
have a
medium with gain in comes the vacuum
fluctuation the vacuum fluctuation
causes an induced emission in that
medium
that's a spontaneous emission if you
want to call it that and you can
tailor that so that another photon comes
along with it so they're two photons
and those photons can either be noisy in
amplitude or noisy in phase
and in different frequency regimes of
the gravitational wave detector
you use one way or the other way and
that was an invention that was made by
carlton caves
interesting among other things yeah so
on that front you know uh the
there's a as you know there's a lot of
lore about ligo
it's a wonderful story it's a tale of
many
you know hundreds of millions if not a
billion dollars it's a tail light
there's a billion dollars
yeah saying running it's a 50 million a
year to run it
yeah exactly yeah everybody always says
oh this new collider will cost 20
billion dollars and i'm like yeah and
500 million a year to run it um but i
say um
you know when jenna levin who's a friend
of mine she's been on the show multiple
times
and she she wrote a beautiful book about
it which you're a major character in
yeah i know the book
and uh and i know you guys have had
conversations but
it's a wonderful story and part of the
story is the suspense like
will they detect it or won't they detect
it and i'm want to pose kind of a little
bit of a provocative question to you
when you set out to measure this a you
had einstein again we're going to keep
talking about your friend uh
albert over here you had einstein the
genius who'd most of his predictions
panned out in one form or another except
you know even his blunder was a blunder
because
we now later found out dark energy was a
necessity to include in our cosmological
model
but um but when i try to measure with my
colleagues on the simon's observatory or
bicep
we try to measure inflationary
gravitational waves we don't have like
hulse and taylor you know standing in
the background saying hey thank us guys
you know we measured that gravitational
waves are real yes we didn't directly
detect them
but i mean was it really such a surprise
i mean tell me
the honest truth did you did you really
doubt that you would ever
make a detection of gravitational waves
or that they existed
well okay well you've entered that the
realm of science history there
yes i mean the book that tries to
explain a little about is kennefick's
book and then yeah do you know daniel
kennefick
i i know i haven't read that book i've
read harry collins book but
the hell with collins's books take a
look at daniel kenovich who is
careful he's a physicist yeah and he and
he has written a beautiful history of
just what you asked about
okay and it goes way back it goes back
to 1916.
i don't know if you know that no i mean
that was right after the the general
theater yes
and then and then the very first thing
that i wanted i mean i'll tell you now
that just to whet your appetite yeah
uh it turns out 1915 is of course the
the full theory comes out
okay in 1916 he writes a paper on the
perturbation theories that you can
use so you don't have to solve the
metric exactly okay
and he picks a couple of examples uh
then the perhaps advance again
and uh he shows that there's newtonian
limit and he introduces gravitational
waves for the first time
and he does everything right he gets the
kinematics right
and he takes a big guess that they
travel at the velocity of light which we
now know to an exquisite precision
but then he completely screws up the
relationship between the source
and the field okay the two sides of the
equation
in other words no he finds that a system
that
this equation you'll find right in the
sort of near the end of the
the paper you have to read a little
german but now it's translated you don't
have to be dragged yeah
yeah so so uh anyway uh well you'll find
out that the all the terms in the
are terms that have to do with the
second derivatives of the
moment of inertia of a system and it
turns out the signs for all the terms
are positive
those make it great so that says a thing
that's spherically symmetric that
expands uniformly
and contracts uniformly will radiate
that's a no-no
okay it goes back even before yeah
okay so it turns out but in that paper
at the very end of the paper
he starts doing a little bit of what a
dimensional analysis
even though he had the thing wrong but
the numbers are still not
wrong in other words the orders of
magnitudes of
the strains the amount of the metric
terms they're still about right they're
just
for the wrong motions okay because it
has much of it right
and it turns out he makes one very very
simple statement at the end he says
here is an equation which the equation
writes down and he
it says you know it this this thing we
have just been talking about in this
paper
will never have any influence in physics
yes it's much too small to even
be contemplated he said that about
gravitational lensing
no he said that about gravitational
waves yeah i know he said about both and
both of them
yeah well yeah but this one i i've
given talks trying to invent what albert
was thinking about
you know and and indeed if you look what
he knew at his time
it was impossible you're talking about
strains of 10-42
okay i mean that's for a train smashing
into another train
in in the radiation zone makes a strain
of 10-42
and that's the biggest thing you can
think of that you can make that's
unmeasurable
and then he looks at binary systems and
sees that binary stars and with a period
of a year
uh you know will tell dale yes they'll
they'll do what
taylor hulse have but they he recognizes
they should fall toward each other but
at the rate they fall toward each other
is so small that you have to wait
something like turn 10 to 12 years 10 to
13 years to see it you can use the
telescope you'd never see it
so anyway that he comes to that
conclusion and uh so then he hasn't in
1918 he writes another paper which is
solely about gravitational waves
and he gets right now the relationship
between
the dynamics of the source and the field
but he doesn't
say anything about the the believability
of seeing it
okay so okay good old fen kenific will
tell you about that
but then he'll take it in 1936 where he
really gets himself into trouble
again with one of the immigrants okay
and uh this is a paper where he is with
um i'll forget the name of the
is like i'm sorry i can't dredge it up
right away
it's the paperwhere which they he and
x who is name i'm trying to remember
submit to the physical review
uh they solved to see if there is a
solution of the einstein equations which
is purely radiative
in other words you know that you have a
really
rigorous solution that is source free in
effect
and can it propagate as a radio and they
prove to
they prove that it can't be done and so
they this
physical review gets this do you know
about this yeah i mean
i mean i i vaguely but i don't think the
audience will know about it so that's
worth continuing
well so any rate uh the um
and so what happens is they they publish
it a guy named robertson the the metric
you know who was at princeton robert
richard robertson i think it is i don't
remember
it gets it to the review and
takes a while for the review to take
place einstein gets miffed about that
hasn't been published yet he calls a
physical review
what's going on with his paper by ex
and einstein and uh and he gets
told that well they send the things out
for review and he gets pissed off at
that
and i don't know if you know that that
was legitimate in germany they don't do
that
right and uh and so uh okay and then
they
robertson's review gets there and
einstein sees what he did they wrong and
they
then in chagrin sought effectively
submitted to the franklin institute
journal
okay so mistakes are all over the place
uh any at any rate the the final mistake
and the one that we had to live with and
that's why we
are we're specifically worried and i i
don't know if barry told you this and
chip will certainly tell you this i'll
tell you is that it was the disaster
associated with
with weber mm-hmm yeah i was just going
to get to know that yeah please go on
yeah
yeah yeah i mean i knew i knew webber
pretty well because during kobe i
i would go visit him a lot you know he
was right there
next to goddard so i went to meena yeah
he's sort of a pitiful
you know pathetic character in some ways
but he was a great scientist right he
said he's a very good scientist i mean
some people will reject what i just said
but and
and i'll tell you what the what the
trouble is he didn't have enough
self-criticism
the ability to be self-critical that's i
think the fundamental trap that he fell
into
would you say that's like confirmation
bias like he saw what he wanted to see
and describe
i can't prove you that that i can't do
but he i can tell you what i know for a
fact yeah please
uh and that is that uh i would visit him
by the time i he had published i mean it
really became
more he published in 69 that he had
detected gravitational waves
right and i kept started going to
goddard a lot
for kobe in 1972. okay really kobe
started that early
yeah well john mather invented kobe and
uh as a graduate student oh
okay all the fts and everyone have you
ever had john on your little program
no i know john but i haven't had him on
i'm going to have him oh boy you'll be
fascinated yeah yeah yeah i will okay
okay and uh so
what happened is that uh um i started
realizing that whoever was
a lot of people i mean the weber thing
went on a lot of people didn't see
anything
that caused a great deal of problems and
for example there were physical society
meetings where
a guy like richard garwin who was a very
good scientist at the ibm and colombia
had built a little bar much more
technically
sophisticated than the one that weber
had built
and he knew exactly how sensitive it was
he knew everything in the noise about it
and he said he didn't see anything and
webber only defense was you didn't do it
my way
and that's not a defense you see that do
you think
do you think uh ray that he might have
been felt burned from the experience
that he had with towns
and the mazer no that that's a he didn't
know that was a not
he he felt i don't know about that one
you know that was the place where he
should
he didn't vote with his feet you
understand what do you mean how do you
mean
what i mean by that is it was he wrote a
paper on negative temperatures
in in a triple ieee an ire journal okay
towns had written it in a physics
business and actually was working on it
and a lot of people in microwave
spectroscopy were trying to figure out
how what to do next and he didn't
it didn't look particularly attractive
to him i know at least he wasn't going
to do an experiment to look for negative
temperatures
but he may have wrote the paper and so
he as i say didn't vote with his feet he
didn't actually go out and do the do the
experiment
and uh the experiment was done by towns
and others
with ammonia you know and so but yes i
look that was a sad story but i
the import the important part is that
here he invented a lot of things which
we now use
for the gravitational wave thing he
invented the idea that
you want to look for a strain he had it
differently than we have it he was
looking for tidal force but that's just
a way of writing it
uh we look for an actual change in the
geometry it's the same story
uh just another way of talking about it
and uh
the uh and then he had the idea that
there would be a non-gaussian
character to the noise and he had to
have coincidence coincidence experiments
and we'd do the same thing yeah and uh
but he had the idea that
and it was like the people who worked
with him at that time with john wheeler
where wheeler actually suggested to him
to look into
how one might detect gravitational waves
and they spent time together
that kip will tell you all about that
yeah so uh
anyway no the sad part is that that when
it came to
defending what he had as a this
measurement
he didn't do it in a way that most
scientists would do he just he said you
didn't do it my way
and that is not a way you he didn't
discuss the sensitivities he didn't
discuss
how he measured his sensitivity he you
know eventually
all of that was done but he didn't
actually talk about now let's compare
the notes how did you do it how did i do
it
he just said you didn't do it my way
yeah so it wasn't collaborative and
that was never collaborative and it was
quite hostile but i can't say richard
garwin was
friendly either i mean you know he might
not have been but he but he
look take a guy like richard garwin and
you pay attention to him he's no dummy i
mean
and uh so uh the uh anyway what happened
is i noticed the following when i
i got very interested what might be
troubling him after i taught a general
relativity course at mit the students
got
fascinated by by by this is before he
published they were very interested
how you could measure gravitational
waves and i knew only about the weber
bar
and in that course i invented the idea
of free masses that's a separate story
but uh and um but the uh and other
people have thought of it too it's just
that the better way better way of doing
it
but what happened is i i had an
undergraduate who was interested in it
and i said look why don't we find out
maybe this guy's measuring magnetic
pulses
and so i built a little coil you know
a helm a little coil and with a with
this electronics to store
signal it says store the pulses that
might be measurable magnetic
coil multiple turn coil about the size
of a armchair okay
had one in my house in newton
massachusetts
another one at the lab in mit and
another one out in chicago where webber
had his
other detector and we saw typically
two or three pulses a day that was
simultaneous and what were they they
were
ten to the minus three gauss lasting for
about ten to minus three seconds
okay where the what the hell was that
and i went with that
well one of those visits to to to weber
during the kobe days
i gave him our list of our the when we
thought we'd seen things
and he was totally disinterested
and what he effectively said do you
think i'm so stupid not to think of
magnetic field
oh so he was uh he was uh oppositional
and he was um
yeah and that's right that was enough
for me
to say well look you know here's this
thing that you you don't know yourself
what it is
you at least have you actually measured
the magnet i mean it was insulting to
him
that that that somebody would come along
with that was like beneath him right
and i wonder you know with with
scientific collaborations
uh many of them are very fraught uh
there's oftentimes
you know clamoring for credit for
recognition sometimes for
prizes they were study done by a
historian of science like how many
collaborations stay together
after the nobel prize is awarded to one
or two of them and
most of them dissipate for one reason or
another i have heard from
some of my listeners that they felt they
should have been included in
the nobel prize in 2017. i won't get
into that uh
necessarily with you but i want to know
more generally speaking
how was it how i mean obviously it was
important but how difficult was it to
construct what
you know doris kearns goodwin would call
a team of rivals with caltech on one
side of the
of the uh of the country and and mit on
the other
and you guys are kind of rivals in a
certain sense you can compete for
students
i'll tell you what the real problem was
it was a problem look there's no denying
it and
in this book that that chip and all of
the group of us are trying to write
we're trying to deal with that
oh good because it's not trivial it
turns out to be extremely difficult
what was really the problem and now i
will commit it comes down to one
real problem it's less to do with
it has less to do with rivalry that i
think is the wrong word
it has to do with style of doing style
of doing
okay and what
what never the and i hear i blame ron
not so much me i i mean i'm i can be
tough to deal with also but
it was it was a different problem the
problem was
that ron a very clever guy let's say
exactly
a lot of the ideas that made our
detection possible
several of them are due to iran but not
exclusively
to iran for example one of the most
important ones
called power recycling was also invented
by one of the german scientists
who was at the goshen zuru had started
working on this
as well uh one of the ideas that the
other very important idea i think the
one that he's singularly responsible for
is how to lock a laser to a
a to a to a to a cavity in other words
you have a
phobia pro cavity how do you do it and
what many of us did not think of this
the guy who had thought of it first was
uh bob pound the same guy who did the
the most valuable
yeah but he did it during the time when
he was in rad lab i don't know have you
ever worked with a klystron in your life
yes yeah i mean not black i got a good
sunburn from it once yes
yeah klystron really well that mean i
mean they're miserable devices
i mean they're more visible i don't know
if they're more miserable than
magnetrons but they're pretty miserable
and then but what bob pound did is
during the war uh
second world war he invented a very
clever technique for
locking a klystron to a microwave cavity
and it's and that idea was then repeated
by by by driver in optical in an optical
setting
and it worked beautifully and so i want
to give the credit to both
pound but mostly to drawn for thinking
about that and that now
is a tool that is used by everybody
in everything that involves lasers and
getting single frequencies
right called pound driver hall uh
locking okay
so look i don't want to take away from
ron anything it's just that here
the problem you do have to realize that
is that he was a child
that's the problem and it's even comes
back to
things that must have been true when he
was a young kid
the transition he couldn't make is a
transition that a lot of people can't
make
and that is from tabletop physics where
you are making
all the decisions with your graduate
students and he barely listened to his
graduate students
and he never listened to his own postdoc
i mean he he would order what to be done
that was a nest
very unfortunate part of the way he
operated so he never got the benefit the
best
use out of the people who worked with
him okay
and that will be in that unfortunately
that'll be in our history
but here comes the real problem why did
we get into trouble we got into trouble
because i was ambitious
about which had to do with mit more than
caltech
i was ambitious because of the way mit
was looking at the whole field of
gravitational
wave physics at that time when i started
mit wanted no part of it and and i
couldn't put graduate students on
the prototype why because it was a
engineering fight
right yeah it wasn't yeah and there
wasn't going to be any science coming
out of it and i was told that many many
times
and so i they weren't going to risk a
graduate student's life on a thing which
didn't look to them
like it would be worth the trouble so
and there was
nobody at mit who believed in black
holes at the time
phil morrison who was probably you may
not know but maybe you do
yeah i know bill was dead against i mean
he would invent the most
most incredible schemes to make it so
you didn't have to invoke a black hole
for the ex what the x-ray astronomers
were seeing so consequently there was no
sympathy for black holes at mit at all
so they felt their it was the technology
was too hard
and also there were no sources anyway
the hell with them and so
i was in a very complicated situation
and uh
uh the and what came of it is that
um i felt the only way i could stay in
business
at mit in in this business is to
immediately start pushing for
a ligo a full-scale thing because i
could prove on paper i had proved
you could not do it with a small device
okay so there was a mindset that was
already different between ron and myself
that was
when ron got into this thing which was
some number of years later
i already because of the experience with
having to prove that there was science
in this
i had made this next step even though
not everything was working yet i said
look
if i'm going to work on this thing it's
got to be on us on a scale it'll be
scaled up it can't
be scaled up we're going to have new
problems when we do that we gotta find
out what those problems are do they
think the 40 meter at caltech could
detect any to do any science yeah well
that's what ron's
in his secret his little in his secret
little head
he kept thinking he's gonna do an end
run around all of this okay
and um so you know it's absolutely true
that's what was going on in his head
um i mean uh and
the so what happened is here's the
tragedy this is where the tragedy
happens
it happened that i was already had made
the transition from tabletop
to bigger physics and ron had not
and he could and there's a difference in
style when you make that
you the style is a small group and you
were running it yourself
there's not that much money involved yet
well you know yourself you've been
through this
yeah of course and then when you go to
something big you you have groups you
have subsystems you have organization
and that's where the thing fell apart it
reminded me of you know sort of like
apple computer or something like that
you know they start off and they're in
their garage
and then they're those that say we can
change the world you know i just need to
build a bigger garage basically
and then there's a those that think you
know it's just this is what got us here
and so
we you know we we have to keep this the
spirit alive and
you see a lot of companies you know go
out of business i always say that
entrepreneurs
and experimental physicists uh have a
lot in common i mean
we both have budgets to manage we have
people to manage we have travel
we don't make any profit in fact we lose
money on every sale
but you know i don't disagree with you
yeah but the motivation is different
but how did you personally deal with
that so i i have to say i i paint a
little bit more of
a sympathetic i didn't know him at all i
never met him when i was at caltech but
but you know i i make the point in my
book in losing the nobel prize here
i'm going to send you a copy because i
don't know if i gave you one but uh but
the point
that i make in the in the in the book is
you guys made the announcement in say
february 10th of 2016 and that was 10
days after the
nomination deadline had closed for nobel
prize nominations of which i was one of
the nominators that year
for the 2016 nobel prize and i kept
waiting because i had heard this rumor
from lawrence krauss
that there was big news coming out of
ligo and i remember i gave a colloquium
there in september
at mit september of what september 2015
right right when you guys were analyzed
well that was the day it happened no no
it was it was uh september
20th it was like a week or two we okay
i'll tell you that one
okay that's important that you get that
one right yeah okay okay
so let me tell you yeah we didn't know
what the hell we had
okay he says you did kraus says you did
no well he what the hell does he know
he's a theorist i know larry and he was
he was
sniffing around i i mean i he heard
because of the collaboration you know
there are people i don't know where he
got it
from feed the people at arizona i don't
know who gave him
this bad piece of information but we
didn't know what we had
okay and for and let me give you some of
the drama that went on between
the 14th of september 2015.
february and february whenever the hell
we published to the third tenth would
have had forgotten
2016. that was held by paleo going on
inside of ligo
i mean we thought the very first thought
it was
i don't know you know this story or not
i don't know i i probably know it but my
audience may not
share it okay okay well i mean the thing
is that uh we thought the very first
thing
we had put we had already done putting
blind injections into the data
that's famous story yeah and uh well we
turns out that with the very first
everybody went around sniffing around
the people who were going to make the
blind injections hadn't even written the
software yet
okay so that was out but it took a day
to find that out
but that didn't end it but that that was
easy
the next one was how do we know we
weren't hacked hackers yeah
and that took a long time because what
happened all during that time i remember
we were living with the paul
of weber in our in our heads yeah and
bicep too
right i mean uh bicep two is a different
story
i know it's an announcement of
gravitational wave well i look i i
the day that happened i went and talked
to um
oh who's the guy from jpl who was on the
bicep team and make sure
he talked jamie i said jamie why did you
do this
we remember our committee we said
you need more channels you can't do it
with ah
yeah well and then i remember andy who's
saying to me look we ought to at least
find out what's there that's fine that's
what the idea was
yeah but then to publish that was a
piece of
of of bad judgment i thought yeah and i
i mean no i don't want to
dump on you guys look i dump on myself
in the book
i quote andrew i quote andy andrew used
to say
you know the the first thing we'll do is
discover if there's any there there
and then we'll follow it up and we did
everything except for follow it up and
and uh but you're right you were saying
that really wasn't affecting a paul
a shadow the way weber did thirty years
very different the weber thing we had
gone
to the point where people were writing
books about it being a
pathological science okay and
and in fact garwin was responsible in
part for that because he was
that's a whole story internal to ligo
from 1986.
i mean when he's when garwin saw that
ligo
was becoming something that they were
even contemplating in the nsf
uh we'll get back to the story in a
minute but uh gargarwan
uh sent a letter to the head of the
the physics division who he knew for
other reasons
and said look if you're going to
continue in this idea
and it wasn't written in a nasty way but
it was written with if you're going to
continue with something that could
embarrass the nsf like this
okay that's the tone of the thing you
ought to have a summer study of this
and we we got a summer study together i
did it personally
so we forced the sun they forced a
summer study on us and they gave us very
good
review but but thou the thing is that
darwin
thought that the whole thing the whole
idea of gravitational waves
was something that was colored by the
arguments that he had with weber
okay and we lived with that and um
so that's why we were being especially
careful and so the let's go back to the
um to the to the the hacker hypothesis
the hack up hypothesis took us almost
four or five weeks to get out to get
get get rid of it and then we had a very
good man within the ligo and
matt evans who's now associate professor
at mit
uh who took it on he took a made a team
out of
looking first of all looking did the
hacker get into the
software did the hacker get into the
into the
tapes that recorded the data did the
hackers get into the
hardware did the hackers get into the
the photo detectors
did they get into the laser i mean in
other words how how did they do it and
right
at the time and they kept studying and
they said look we even locked up all the
instruments you couldn't open the the
the chassis because we had tape on them
because we didn't want anybody to mess
with it
so it was a i mean one tremendous thing
and
eventually they never could prove we
could never prove there was no hacker
but the hackers had gotten so smart that
they knew so much
that it became very implausible right
and so
but that isn't the end of it it turns
out
it looked like we could not rule out
that but it looked implausible it looked
easier to say nature did it and then for
many of us and you can ask barry this
also
maybe maybe you did what was the thing
that finally triggered it that you were
willing to go forward and it was this
that it was the
christmas the day after christmas boxing
day event
that's right that's right yeah he said
that as well and you know i i i
questioned what would have been the
history of science what would it look
like if that event
didn't occur in this galaxy uh far far
away
and then he said it was all but you know
it was it would have been it would have
been you know a couple of months later
yeah and then you had the binary neutron
star oh that's two years later that's a
whole other
i mean that must have been a whole other
level of kind of uh confirmation i mean
you must know there are people
in the in in europe at least and maybe
in the us who claim that there are
you know there are challenges still with
the interpretation you know we all
know and i want to you know because i
know you don't have you know
the too much more time but i do want to
ask you you know specifically
about um you know some things i did talk
to to barry about
that involved maybe the future of this
type of science
and that involves you know the the
question of which is more scientifically
interesting to you well let me first ask
you a question i've asked this
of of of people like shelley galashau
and frank wilczyk and others
and roger penrose that we talk about
black holes
as if they're real and we sort of know
that they're real but the fact that we
know that they're real and you are one
of the main people on earth that's
responsible for the
actual visceral feeling of reality that
they connote
but um how do we know that we can take
the leap
from there to saying that they have a
singularity at their core
and i've i've pressed this with roger
penrose and i i haven't gotten a
satisfactory
uh response from anybody and maybe maybe
you will provide the first satisfaction
so you won't get it from me
i'll tell you what the way we
established it was a black hole
it was only from two things it was from
the
the fact that the cursed solution you
know what the occur
is the guy who did a rotating black hole
yeah um
that the cursed solution which is
nothing more really than adding
a minimum it's just more mathematics
it's another model for a black hole
that that predicted
and be careful there's one step further
if it hadn't been for numerical
relativity i don't know if people told
you that
but if it hadn't and kip will certainly
emphasize this when you talk to him
if it hadn't been for numerical
relativity most of the people would not
have been
they would queasy about it because the
last splash
the last let's say few oscillations of
that waveform
where this velocity is close to one
half the velocity of light the relative
velocity of 0.6 the velocity of light
none of the post newtonian expansions
that you can make of
relativity you can do that you can do it
to in order is a power of v over c
you can do a metric expansion in powers
of v over c
and you have to go to some incredible
order 11th order or something like that
and you know i don't know if you've ever
done these goddamn things there
everybody who does them
you make a sign error and the whole
thing blows up on you it's no good
i mean it's just endless paper i mean
well yeah i mean
i remember walking around caltech and
the halls of west bridge and hearing
sterl finney's office
and he would visualize the church
like all day long i thought i go crazy
listening to that all day no but that's
okay the chirp is not the least
it's getting it right to the end point
yes and and the thing is the chirp comes
straight out of newtonian physics i mean
you don't have to do much with a little
bit of the quadrupole formula
so you can get the first part of the
thing very beautifully
but you're asking how much of the black
hole's mystique
do we know of its essence and the
essence of the black hole and you will
really know the black hole being
different than a neutron star
only from two things and i think we're
close to it
if not already proved it there is
uh the solution the dynamics the current
solution dynamics
uh gives you the waveform we see and you
can compare the waveform we have
with a numerical relativity waveform
that is now good to
arbitrary uh up to well not i don't know
if it's good at
exactly c but it's goddamn close to it
okay
and you the two match they match i mean
they match to
as the signal the noise in the in the
measurement mm-hmm
so that's giving you the confidence that
at the end well that's part of what
gives you the confidence
but what's even more important that came
after the paper was written
two things have happened that paper was
that we've also now begun to see
the normal mode oscillations of the
metric around the black hole
in other words when the two black holes
come together and they form
uh things quiet down but there is still
oscillations going on on
in the met in the geometry of course
okay
and they're going on and they have
normal modes they turned out they're
quite heavily damped by
gravitational radiation those have begun
to speed up we can begin to smell at
them
and that is distinct from say a compact
object
that's a state from a neutron star okay
okay uh
now what it tells you about the
singularity inside the black hole i
don't know i
don't know enough theory word that has
an event horizon you know that
i mean the event horizon telescope you
know i'm trying to get shep dolmen on
the podcast but i've had on other people
and uh you know that what we're really
seeing in that mystical image that we
saw over a year ago now it's almost two
years ago
is the light shadow you know it's not
you see more than that
now you're seeing two things okay you've
seen the light shot the spin yeah
that's the yeah that's the input one of
the things you're seeing but
the light shadow is the black part but
you're also seeing something else you're
seeing the photon ring
that's a ring that forms outside as
we're going away from the black hole
we're coming out from the black hole
toward
toward us so the first thing you see
that's closest into the
hole is the dark the dark part
okay now that can be seen better if shep
had more
detectors and that's what he's doing
right now working on that now yeah
because they had a lot of
they had to do a lot of modeling to get
that you see okay and he knows exactly
what has to be done
then the the bright part that ring you
saw
is something which is a very different
thing that's quite far away from the
event horizon
but that's the next event in that
picture and what is that
these are photons that have come in
with close enough to r equal to the
event horizon but not yet at our event
horizon
and they get captured in a ring and what
happens is they are
they collide with each other the photons
in that ring there's perturbations of
that ring
effectively they come about because of
and that they sometimes leave the ring
and that's what you're seeing
yes the trajectories it's a photon ring
but you haven't seen the event horizon
right you're not going to see that yeah
so nor will you see the singularity and
here's what i often see the singularity
you will never see there's only one
singularity in that damn
black hole it's not the event horizon no
i know yeah it's it's the thing that's
deep inside of it
that tears everything apart right well
here's my
here's here's my uh you know my what do
you call it fracas or my
complaint against the you know this
notion of singularities
i feel there's a lot of circular logic
in other words we'll hear things like we
need
a quantum theory of gravity because we
don't know how to explain
the properties of matter and energy
and gravitational fields at uh small
distances and high energy in other words
we don't understand it and where do we
find
two scenarios where fundamentally
gravity
seems to need a quantum analog to it
like a graviton description
and that is at the singularity of a
black hole and possibly at the
singularity at the big bang
and you guys you guys are going to find
it
i mean that's the thing so this is what
i want to ask you you're no no but but
but wait a minute that's very important
that to me is the next most important
thing that's going to happen in this
field
now where the b modes do it and i i
hope they do i hope you can get around
all the foregrounds
and i think i don't know if r or .001
will do it
i know that's about what you can do yeah
what i've heard
i hope it can do it but that's not
that's at the end
that's not the end of the story i think
if you see something
or if you don't see something the next
generation of people who go into
the business in the gravitational wave
detection will push like hell for
something that can do it
that can actually measure it okay so but
but that that will be called i don't
know if you know this it's called
big bang observer yes yeah i talked to
her i talked to um
barry a little bit about the future but
but i guess i i still haven't made the
the final point which is that
even if we see b modes we're not seeing
gravitons we're seeing the classical
analog i don't want to and certainly
we'll never see the singularity in a
black hole so
my question is what if there is no big
bang my friend paul steinhardt
my friend and your fellow laureate now
officer roger penrose
they have very bright minds they have
super brains right
and they don't believe there was a
singularity at all in fact they believe
evolution is purely classical and so my
question is
is there a generation of young theorists
that are perhaps wasting their time
because they're pursuing something which
can never be seen in the case of a
singularity at the core of a black hole
or may not exist in the case of a
singularity at the origin of time so
i mean you're asking a hard question for
a person i'm not a theorist but i
i my prejudice is that
it would be quite quite amazing giving
all the analogies
between electricity and magnetism and
and and analogies
they're not perfect analogies and i can
give you many many examples
where the analogies break down but there
is enough
there that i think it would be a miracle
to me if there wasn't a quantum theory
of gravity
interesting there's got to be i mean why
should that be left out
and the thing is that not that we have
seen it and many people say well
can't you do that by looking at the
granularity of the waveforms you're
looking at
well i wish we could but you know you're
dealing with see
the number of gravitons in there is you
know the in the 10 to the 30 department
you know that kind of thing
yeah so it's not and and looking for
what you're asking about looking for
some
evidence of the singularity in the black
hole
that you can see from the outside of the
black hole is probably
iffy one place where i think you might
be able to do something
is from the spectrum of the of the
the spectrum of the uh gravitational
radiation that
you may not see in b modes because
you're going to see an integral yeah
but that you could do if you actually
looked over a few frequency bands yeah
so if you had like a the big bang
observer
plus the cmb and you both detect it yeah
you'll get what's called the tensor
spectral index and that would be
you know um you know at least some more
circumstantial if not convinced
well i'll tell you i mean the fact is
that i i just really will love this
story
um is that i went during the kobe days
uh i would occasionally i would i go
from mit to
the goddard a lot and on one of occasion
uh
alan guth wanted to go to give a talk at
um
at goddard about you know where kobe was
going and you want to give the people on
kobe a
little pep talk about what this new idea
and so
i'm driving on uh that road on the the
highway to washington from the
baltimore airport and uh we've been
talking and talking and talking
and i finally asked him you know don't
you think there might be gravitational
waves
that come from inflation
and he didn't say anything for a while
um and what we knew at that time
a lot of people had guessed that include
including steve weinberg
that maybe there would be a one degree
kelvin background of gravitational waves
which of a plunking variety which is
absolutely hopeless to detect
okay and uh when we got to the gates at
the goddard
and he said to me probably not and
there probably are none and so they hear
starabinsky's papers on
what might have happened and the
difference between allen and
and and sarabinsky is alan didn't
he had particles that did it but he did
the calculation classically
starabinsky did it as particles but
quantum mechanically
and to him the big thing that caused the
gravitational waves were the
fluctuations
interesting the quantum fluctuations are
what caused
the the gravity waves and that's a
spectrum that
anybody who's working in that field now
uses as i mean there are other
points less less well-defined like for
example phase transitions from different
epics right that's certainly there but
the thing is that if it's there
but the one that that actually has to do
with inflation has to do with the
quantum theory
and if sterobinsky's right that's the
only way i think you're going to get any
evidence for the quad for the graviton
interesting okay so it would be that
yeah the spectral
kind of this encrypting very interesting
i want to turn to a couple of questions
from my friends and your friends uh that
are at
mit so one comes from uh professor max
tegmark
and he asked me to ask you why did your
dean
draw a huge zero on a piece of paper
decades ago well i think i told you that
in about half an hour ago yeah okay
that's the
lack of backing that i think was uh not
pre
you know kip and barry and and ron
didn't have to contend with that i mean
caltech has had a long history
oh yeah mainly thanks to kip right uh
well it's more than that
i mean i give kipp and caltech credit
for the fact that we didn't the whole
field didn't go under yeah okay
yeah i mean and and i can i have in that
book we're writing i
i have if my sentence stays in the book
it was a
it was a watershed for the field that
caltech went into this
did you ever think of leaving mit uh
it's hard
when you have how old are your kids i've
got well i've got five of them and nine
nine
down to two well they're not old enough
yet they're not old enough you could
still move
is that an offer are you propositioning
me really i'm not proposition
i'm very happy here i would i would also
have to deal with a death sentence from
my wife
what i'm talking about is that once you
have a interest in boyfriends and
girlfriends
and you you have become part of the
society and that means you become an
adolescent it's very hard to move kids
no i know and and i love it here it's
it's phenomenal but and i love
mit the mit is a wonderful institution
i'll tell you one cute story about
this about that one of my colleagues
david shoemaker
and i had gotten quite desperate about
this and
david is one of the older gentlemen in
in in the field now but
and we had thought this is back in we
had it made an offer
indirectly by stanford and it wasn't
whether we didn't know it was stanford
or stanford accelerator that was making
the offer
that to take the whole laboratory our
laboratory they knew about
problems that was not a mystery to
anybody right um
and uh they uh
at stanford and so what happened is he
and i went out there to try to sniff it
out
see if there was anything it looked
pretty good they wanted to build the
ligo next to the accelerator they wanted
to have
and they're working on gpb right yeah
yeah but that's part of the story
so anyway we get to the we're getting to
the we're getting to the down you know
down to it
joe taylor was in particular one of the
guys who was very anxious to see
gravitational waves at cal tech
so i went to speak with um uh the
the head of the department who was they
then later became head of the department
of energy
uh chu steeps you know yeah
and i go into his office and uh he looks
me square in the face and he says
look it says we've got one crazy
experiment we don't need two
matt ended it yeah i talked to clifford
will
about this not too long ago yeah he was
uh he was on some of the review
committees for this 50-year long
experiment which uh
some say was a was a huge boondoggle but
somehow they kept getting funded and
funding
i tell you i have a different view they
they measured it they do
yeah oh i think i think they did but how
long did it take how many careers did it
take how much money did it take and
what did it do to stanford i mean it was
a huge you know albatross according to
many of my friends i was a postdoc there
during the late 90s and you know a lot
of people felt a lot who were you were
with you
was church i was with sarah church yeah
and before she fired me but that's a
that's a story for another time
i want to end with one other question
before i get to the question i ask all
my
uh guests that are honored honoring me
by your presence and this is from david
kaiser
who is a professor uh alongside yeah
so uh we talked about um you know how it
was to to kind of
work on on projects when when it was
sort of
considered to be almost like fringe and
and
i i wonder you know you're kind of
different because it was like um i don't
know if you know this guy michael jordan
the basketball player right
so i know the name but i don't know what
he does yeah he was like the
i mean considered the best basketball
player in history and then he quit
and retired at the top of his game and
uh and then he went off and he tried to
play baseball
and it kind of reminds me of you know
like my friend jim simons who's
sponsoring the simon's observatory
his kick lately is that he should win
the nobel prize
uh for this chern simon i know i know
yeah
so you know so i'm thinking you know jim
is worth you know he's an mit grad
uh he's worth billing i didn't realize
yeah he was an undergrad
i think he worked with the singer and he
was in the math department
oh so he worked with a cosmology guy
yeah singer is a complicated man but
complicated siegel is the comp is the
cosmos that's right
he worked with singer uh but but anyway
they're both interesting guys
and uh and i think you know like you had
you had kobe
you know which eventually garnered two
nobel prizes and then you had ligo
and for so long i made the point to to
barry
i think for barry's career the
cancellation of the super collider was
like the best thing that could have ever
happened to him
because he went on to go and work on
ligo after that
and if he had stayed with the super
collider and if it had succeeded
he wouldn't have won the nobel prize
because that went to none of the
experimentalists on the lhc
right so i said jokingly and he's like i
don't play those games
but with you you already had kopi i mean
you made this phenomenal impact on on so
many people
on the discovery of something so
foundational and yet you still
kept working on this project that many
people consider to be fringe so what
what give you gives you that courage is
that just the way that you were born or
i mean is there some
tangible lesson that we can learn from
from your experience of having
a super successful thing and then a moon
shot that like could be a big waste of
time and money
well i never think that way see that's
the trouble i don't think the way you're
talking
and uh let me tell you that the nobel
prize or what it at
where it read where this particular
experiment ends whether it's successful
or not
isn't the thing that is in my mind
what's in my mind is it interesting
that's the first question
am i going to do something which isn't
interesting to me or even anybody else
and the another one which is much more
pedestrian is it fun
okay and i found both of those things
kind of fun
and important and they started in my lab
at about the same time
and kenneth you told me over dinner and
we had dinner with alan guth and
and the late great andy friedman who
passed away sadly this year
and max tecmo and you said you know at
any given time there are only
four or five people who fully understand
ligo
from soup to nuts and uh you know i i
wonder
you know can experiments get too big i
don't think there's anybody who
understands like
every aspect of the lhc or maybe even of
the simon's observatory that i'm i'm
working on
um can an experiment get so big that it
loses that interest and fun
factor that made ligo appeal to you so
much well
be careful with that that's see there's
a difference between ligo and
high energy physics still it's not quite
you're not yet regimented completely
and that's something my my my colleague
who
made trouble this is the driver never
really understood
there was still within ligo so many
things that
used your imagination and made you feel
that
yes you had a job to do and if it
succeeded you would have another
interesting thing to work on
and so you still felt within a
constrained
that you couldn't take crazy things on
anymore
but that you were functioning in
something which was very important
and what you were working on was fun
i'll give you many examples
for example uh you know
for a while we were screwed by bark
housing noise that's something i worked
on
why because it was making noise in the
magnets and the that pushed the masses
around
so i did a whole experiment on that and
i came up yeah it turned out it was a
problem
that was fun to work on in the beginning
there was we had done something
completely idiotic we bought
a lot of switching power supplies stay
away from switching power supplies if
you're doing anything delicate
and they were just i mean you couldn't
even walk near the place without getting
a note from the fcc saying you guys are
a radiation hazard i mean a radio
already
so anyway there were many many puzzles
puzzles like uh
endless puzzles that came up and i got
mixed up i'll tell you something very
pedestrian
the vacuum tube the vacuum of the vacuum
tube of the
big long tube in fact that became very
important
in my life for about four years i see so
it turns out everything i touched there
were people who i enjoyed working with
and they were
things that didn't regimen it was they
were still you were still not yet in a
regime
where you couldn't see what was going on
otherwise
i think there are people there are
people in ligo who know enough about
everything part of it
that they can say yeah this if there's a
problem it's probably in this subsystem
interesting so that was kind of micro
projects that add up to the success of
the whole project
and each micro project is is fun in and
of itself
i think that's wonderful so i want to
ask you a couple questions before we
we conclude and these are questions that
i ask uh guests
who all you know honor me on their uh by
coming on my show
and uh and it really you know hearkens
essentially
aspects that are important to me uh of
life outside of physics because i
i think in the conclusion of my book you
know i i lusted after the nobel prize
until i went through this episode where
i came close to you know possibly being
involved with a project for it
and i came to see it as you know a
byproduct over my
shoulder over here you can see maria
gephardt mayer
who won the nobel prize and she has a
quote you can't see it but it says
winning the nobel prize was only half as
much fun as doing the work
and she's right that's good good i'm
glad you have that there yeah so i keep
that
and that's actually on a poster i have
two daughters and i put her poster up
in each one of their rooms and the other
day my older daughter who's four
she said dada is maria still alive and i
said no she's not alive
and then uh and then my daughter she
says
did she die did she
[Laughter]
so i said yeah she died uh but she she
made wonderful contributions okay these
are things that involve
death unfortunately but i'm not gonna
get too too gruesome here ray
but it is the anniversary of alfred
nobel's death he did die
124 years ago in 1896
on this very day that we are speaking
december 10th and that's why they give
the nobel prizes out on us
on this day typically although this year
they didn't do it because stockholm is
locked down right because
so alfred nobel had a will and it said
that the prize should go to
the person who made the greatest
discovery or invention
and conferred the greatest benefit to
mankind
and as you know alfred had no uh wife he
had no kids
he had no errors in that way so he left
basically all of his money to the prize
plus
he endowed what's what we call in hebrew
an ethical will
an azava ah it's it means a wisdom will
what do you want to leave to your heirs
in terms of wisdom that you've
accumulated in your 88 years on earth
and may
live to the biblical age of moses 120
ray we
need you ray uh but i want to ask you
what kind of piece of wisdom would you
leave to
future generations that you've
accumulated well
you're going to be very um you're going
to be very upset with me okay i can tell
you that already
and that's the advice that i give
everybody but i give it to myself also
if it isn't fun get the hell out of it
that's great okay that is perfect thank
you ray
okay next one is a question i ask you've
seen the movie 2001 a space odyssey with
uh
i don't know it now well there's a
there's a scene in it we can uh
skip over part of it i do want to note
that there was a voyager satellite
uh that carl sagan hears a puppet of
carl say someday we'll get a puppet of
you right
i have a puppet of noam chomsky your
neighbor dude yeah
uh but i'll get a puppet of yours he's
still alive right no he's he's dead yet
no he was on my show or uh earlier this
year actually i think he's younger than
you
i think he was born no he's the same age
he was born in 1932 on december 7th so
he just turned 88
so he's a little younger than i am a
couple months a couple like couple of
months
exactly um so uh there's a there's a
plaque
a fix a golden disk a fixed with a
phonograph needle can play it
that they put carl sagan convinced nasa
to put this record
on the voyager satellite that contained
sounds of planet earth
and it was meant i actually talked to
carl sagan's widow andrew
and she runs this cosmos program on tv
and is written books
and she actually had her brain waves
recorded
and transcribed onto this phonographic
disc which appeals to your past
upbringing
uh and your experiments that we talked
about at the very beginning of this
podcast
but this this disc is meant to last for
a billion years and it's sort of a time
capsule that will go out into
infinity so to speak hopefully you'll be
discovered and
and on it is inscribed all these
wonderful things
i want to know if you had your own
billionaire time capsule
what would you put on it you know
richard feynman said this as a famous
cataclysm
you know destroyed all of all of
scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence was
passed on to the next generation of
creatures
what sentence would i richard feynman
contain make that contains the most
information
in the fewest words i believe it is the
atomic hypothesis
that all things are made of atoms little
particles that move around i want to ask
you
scientific or otherwise what would you
like to put on a time capsule that would
last
a billion years well that's a hard one
boy i haven't thought about that
but i think the most important thing is
look around and see if you can draw
conclusions
that would be my i mean i don't think i
can tell you anything better than that
yeah it's kind of the experimentalist
uh perspective yeah drawing inferences
from what surrounds us in nature
last question and then i'll let you go
you've been so generous with your time
i want to go instead of going forwards
in time to your ethical will and your
billion-year-old time caps i want to go
backwards in time so
i don't know if you know sir arthur c
clarke or what he said he said a couple
of famous things he said
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable
from magic he said for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert i
like that one
at the faculty lounge i like to use
those those that phrase and then he said
the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them
into the impossible and that's the name
of this podcast uh we're named after
this phrase i want to know what advice
would you give to a 20 year old ray
weiss
from an 88 year old ray wise uh you know
advice to your former self
that seemed impossible back when you
were a youth but now seems eminently
doable because of your courage or
insight
or just sheer drive well i mean that
one's easy
i mean at least for leave you with an
easy one you'll come back when your book
is out
no no no no no what you do is you know
once you've learned a little bit you
can't just and this is one of the
problems that
uh i think a lot of the kids have today
that it doesn't take some investment
to do what i'm about to say okay that
you can
and this i think has happened because of
the barrage of information that comes
from everywhere but
uh you just don't make anything up that
is a very much value until you've
been around to think a little bit about
it that's one of the things but
the thing i would say is make sure that
you keep looking at the fresh ideas that
occur to you
because some of them might actually be
interesting
okay and don't just say it's too hard or
that it's you know if you think there's
something there well it's worth your
time
and uh i can say this with what happened
to me over and over again
i mean you know you some of you start in
a new field
and that's another thing i don't know
you don't always stay in the say you i
don't know what you did but most i say
to most people
look if you don't every five years you
especially as you're young
you get your phd in field x and if five
years later you're not if you're still
doing field decks you haven't asked
yourself enough questions
but you should at least ask yourself the
question am i getting what i like out of
this
is it still fun is it still interesting
and then
you might just jump into something else
that's not the reason i went the
gravitational waves that was there all
the while but
i that's the questioning of is what
you're doing
interesting still to you you know or has
it become a habit
it's something you've got to figure out
for us yeah i'm learning something new
yeah how do you is there something new
that occurred to you and boy it's worth
thinking about that
it is your mind is remarkable i don't
know how it gets stuff
but you know it's amazing what comes out
of it yeah
it's amazing this computer made of fat
you know can do so much stuff
almost makes you religious you got to be
careful yeah you're going to you were
going to tell me something
now here you are keating which is a nice
wasp name that's right irish
are you a good jewish boy from new york
i am tell me what happened
okay well i'm going to send you a copy
of my book so you can read it but the
short story is
both my parents are jewish they're born
biologically jewish
and i was i was you know
raised maybe once a once a year on
christmas
we would go to synagogue maybe or
chinese food that was about the extent
of our judaism
then my parents got divorced and my
mother married an irish catholic man
with
nine brothers and sisters named keating
so i changed my name from
axe to keating when my f my stepfather
adopted me
when i was seven years old and then to
make things even more complicated for
you i became an
altar boy in the catholic church at age
13 which you'll recognize as the age
when
jewish boys are supposed to have their
bar mitzvah exactly never had a bar
mitzvah
i was an altar boy in the catholic
church and i loved it
and then i went to college became an
atheist and then after 9 11
i started to realize this country of
israel seems to be important it seems to
be involved in
a lot of affairs on planet earth and i i
knew nothing about i knew
more about christianity and atheism than
i knew about the religion of my birth
and i was kind of stupid because
i said well christianity came along
after judaism jesus was jewish we know
that
and so they must have like anything that
was wrong with with judaism jesus and
the further christians must have like
kind of tweaked that and made it
like might agree with data or imperial
evidence or whatever
and so i can if i can rule out
christianity as being like i don't
believe
in in this transubstantiation or
resurrection
then i can disprove you know modus
ponens i can disprove
judaism so that's what i did and so i
was an atheist for a long time until
i started to get serious about wanting
to have a family
and get married and learn about this
vast wonderful history that i felt i've
been
kind of um denied and and literature and
so forth so now i study talmud
i read the torah i actually know more at
least i can read hebrew now
and uh and i do want to wish listeners a
happy hanukkah
tonight is the first night of hanukkah
and uh i thank you for that question i'm
gonna send you a copy of this book so
i'll email you for your address ray
and i would love it if you gave it a
read barry read it he enjoyed it and he
wants to talk more about it
as well so hopefully i'll have you and
uh barry and kip
and then i'll have you all back when you
guys come out with your book
next year uh god willing we'll have a
better 2021 than 2020.
i want to thank you so much ray okay
well thank you for the suspect you're a
good interviewer okay
you did well thank you so much i hope we
uh we'll talk again we'll zoom again
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
you